[Musique]
oh
le prénom à nous communiquer non j'ai
réfléchi j'aimerais que notre bébé une
vie normale notre au fonds sera
l'héritier de ce royaume je suis allé à
l'école publique et je prenais le métro
tout seul à 10 ans on trouvera une
nouvelle définition de normes à
l'ensemble mais pas de métro non plus
heureusement pour toi la halle de vie
n'a pas de métro ce soir vous majesté
nous signerons la trêve entre l'al dovi
épingle ia je serai la première reine
elle signe le royaume de penguin est
très attaché aux traditions nous rennes
pouvons mettre la tradition au goût du
jour vous voulez moderniser une
tradition vieille de 600 ans
l'histoire n'est pas faite par ceux qui
suivent les règles je peux aussi vous
offrir nos services
j'ai vu le parchemin c'est un peu
vieillot non c'est une oeuvre d'art
inestimable et j'ai eu le grand honneur
de présider la trêve sacrée entre nos
royaumes pouvez vous procédez s'il vous
plaît
[Musique]
au moins maintenant on peut le remplacer
par quelque chose de plus quand tu m'as
qui dans le tarn et avaient les moyens
l'opportunité et mobile si un jour la
presse venait à être rompu un sens
s'abattra sur le premier mais si le
traité n'est pas signé avant mini la
veille de noël
la malédiction s'accomplira
le traité a disparu et si on ne le
trouve pas notre bébé sera maudit qui va
devoir m'expliquer tout ça c'est une
longue histoire et gestion histoire je
prends le premier avion tu peux me
rapporter des dégâts ne juge pas mes
envies bizarres
[Musique]
tout ira bien
je crois que je ne suis pas prête pour
être reine est maire
l'avion est en stand by nous décollons
des possibles je sais que tu ne crois
pas à cette malédiction mais là j'ai
besoin de temps et on retournera tout
château s'il le faut personne ne fait
noël comme les aldo vient
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'il y a j'arrive même pas
attrapé mes chaussons permettez moi
c'est parfait
[Musique]
tu est celui qui exécute les tueurs de
flics
je vais les retrouver
combien de policiers 8 le pire carnage
juin 18 ans les avaient été appelés pour
un cambriolage
j'ai choisi c'est pas pour rien
je vais les retrouver
si on choque pas ces types dans les
trois ou quatre heures ils disparaîtront
le canton vous faire il y à 21 points
qui permettent de sortir de manhattan
on monte des barrages
on arrête tous les trains on ferme
toutes les stations de métro
ensuite on y monte l'île de flics ça pas
de sens le deal c'était 30 kg et on se
retrouve avec trois cents
il se passe quoi la jeu de la vérité
c'est tout
il mangeait que tu étais une tête brûlée
celui qui exécute les tueurs de flics
et ça me coûte il est à moi
la commission de discipline a décidé
d'appeler su sport de l'ensemble des
corps du score jusqu'à la fin de la
saison
moi je finis la saison mais j'ai une
idée pourquoi pas faire une équipe de
filles pour jeu les trois derniers
matchs et joueuses tu te fous de moi par
contre a déjà vu des mecs jouer contre
des filles soit en foot qui seraient
volontaires mois écoulé huawei mille
écoute les conversations à l'aimer mois
sur le bassin au tombeau voit ça comme
si on faisait ou c'est quoi ces
exercices on n'est pas au club med
oui la dimension de radés bonal en face
de nous il faut mettre 6 2 et puis ce
serait super quittant la machine avec
mais c'est tombé sur des post-it rien
compris mais là tu étais où j'étais
juste football football tu sais le truc
où tu m'emmènes trois dimanches sans me
demander mon avis un mois je garantis
que si vous comprenez je vous le
rappelle cette fois
c'est le combientième ça ya eu des
bonnes choses
c'est notre premier match vous
connaissez pas encore
ça va progresser je veux pas que les
chiens on a commencé ensemble finissent
ensemble on a besoin de toi
marco monde toutes les filles je tenais
vraiment à être remercié grâce à toi
grâce à un boulet fillon visite comme
des choses exceptionnelles
ouais je suis hyper fier il y aura
toujours un espoir du golf
ce qui se passe rien on ferme tout goûté
c'est tout de partout pour noël nous
invitant quatre invités exceptionnels
le présentateur phare du 20 heures la
rock star du stand up l'avez compris
serrés des français
la mascotte de l'équipe de france
moi c'est geronimo il faut de m'appeler
jérôme nous ne pas taper du tout mais on
s'en fout
allez venez regarder la chose qu'on a
la nature nous souhaitons la bienvenue
[Musique]
évidemment nos invités sont impatients
ou un patient pour bienvenue les amis
chez les bâlois pour cette enfance au
bout du bout du gant pokémon et je vais
taper le siège comme tout le monde ça
sera beaucoup plus simple c'est les
photos qui les intéressent
il n'est plus qu' il faut du voodoo avec
abano terme étant renvoyée à deux
reprises et c'est vital
ils ont même tourné chez les pats bull
non ces conneries là pour dégager ce
n'est pas ce que je suis pourtant
derrière l'union à l'époque horaire on
va jouer
il a
ce ne sont pas des gens normaux comme
vous et moi ce sont des gens célèbres et
déteste tout le monde c'est normal
en fait le plus gros fléau d'afrique
c'est vous pardon
west amber normal que ses parts à peu
près de la mienne mais il est
complètement con lui
tu as entendu tout aussi j'ai quelque
chose qui se trouve en bas à la cave
les autorités se trouvant à new york
faisant annoncer une série de vampires
nous avons besoin de vous docteur il y
avait un déficit en hémoglobine chez
toutes les victimes
que savez-vous pour l'instant c'est un
virus modifiés qui transforme l'adn j'ai
besoin que tu m
je suis plus de ce que je suis donné je
suis toujours ton frère je vais trouver
un traitement l'homme que vous
connaissiez s'est volatilisé
mes amis et moi même ne sommes pas des
terroristes nous avons dans le droit des
vivants que vous aussi horrible que ça
vous semble
cette guerre est aujourd'hui nécessaire
de la patrie du sens va triompher
l'infection se propage plus vite qu'on
croyait to see
auld est sensé
mais je crois que je peux vous souhaitez
j'ai besoin de temps
vous nous rejoignez
qu'est ce qu'on va devenir
[Musique]
shi
dr je suis médecin
j'ai lu les nouvelles que tu m'envoies
alors c'est super coq tu écris oui
ma petite
mais je peux peut-être juste pour ce en
quoi est ce qui t'arrange pour noël oui
maman tout me va moi si tu fais le 23
décembre c'est à dire qu'ils préfèrent
juliette mais vraiment tu sais très bien
qu elle est chiante margot je suis
enceinte
je me dis que tu cherchais un
photographe truc c'est ma petite soeur
et photographes ce que je veux c'est
quand tu seras connais je n'utilise que
moi j'étais là moi j'étais là c'est
celui-là c'est son côté pretoria
questionna de ta part une copie dons
sont possibles d'un petit copain droit
intègre sérieux pendant des années
jean-pierre à croquer les nets et en
dehors de sa vie c'est parfaitement
qu'il n'a jamais aimé qu'elle est qu'il
n'a jamais été aimé que pareil tu marié
j'ai une petite fille serait autre que
tu pensais lennon il faisait semblant
d'en sourire on dit comprendre quelque
chose
alors qu'il n'avait jamais rien compris
mais que sait-on biya vie intérieure de
quelqu'un
peut-être que pour connaître quelqu'un
il faut d'avoir les mais avec ce désir
sa mélancolie tué quand on était petits
qui m'avait dit tu serais toujours là
pour moi
alors c'est peut-être ça que j'essaie de
réparer en écrivant et je sais que rien
ne pourra m'arrêter
euh d'or est ce qu'on peut faire
pose pourquoi vous poser toutes ces
questions repartant au début
cette famille est totalement désespérée
lorsque les gens sont désespérés ils
sortent les couteaux
si vous savez quelque chose dicle je
soupçonne un acte criminel
waouh
non si
quoi quoi
[Musique]
tu as trouvé ça sur google me trouvais
ça se trouve elle devrait se réunir plus
souvent
[Musique]
ma mère m'a placé en bout de table entre
les jumeaux de mon frère depuis
j'élabore une stratégie et bientôt je
dirais une phrase qui aura un gros
impact sur moi et sur quelques autres
personnes
écoutez j'ai rencontré quelqu'un sérieux
quoi il faut que tu nous le présente
bientôt à mêler à noël c'est donc comme
ça que je me suis mise dans la merde tu
t'es inventé un mec sérieux
ouais alors il faut que tu te trouves un
mec quoi en 24 jours ouais je te donnera
un coup de main
tu vas trouver les bois d'emmener talent
appelé leurs matches on va pimenter sa
vie amoureuse
regardez sourit plus
[Musique]
alors ça pour une coïncidence johannes
la note est il écrit ici que tu as 29
ans tu me rappelle ma maman
je sais même plus combien de rang car
j'ai eu et tous ces types y font comme
si j'étais pas là ils écoutent rien du
tout oui qui devrait pas juger les
hommes s'est rapidement il faut que tu
vives comme toi tu l'entends ne laissent
pas les autres 10 pts et comment vivre
ta vie
ironie sera bientôt là prenez votre mal
en patience
[Musique]
qu'on soit clair tous les deux je suis
pas plus tôt hier j'ai couché avec un
dragon
j'aimerais qu'on souhaite la bienvenue à
de nouveaux élèves
je vous laisse vous présenter
j'ai souhaité des classes et marne lui
les
il est loué pour plein de choses c'est
quoi ça
tu finiras pas choper est-ce que vous
êtes prêts pour faire ce soir
celle du héros sur le point de débuter
et là qu'est ce que je fais maintenant
voilà votre profil c'est de là que les
gens viendront votre photo donc tout le
monde dorme a fait au mali quand
s'agissait de trois ans toi tu as aimé
que je te like à rennes
j'aimerais vraiment le dédier à internet
ce crédit permet à certains cours et
d'amour et pour ceux qui n'auraient pas
trouvé ma d'aller sur youporn
vous savez ce que c'est un stalter donc
surveiller la vie de quelqu'un sur les
réseaux sociaux
lee rl
ça veut dire quoi vous savez pour toutes
vos questions via un navigateur qui
s'appelle google
j'ai coché
[Musique]